sherry all right mattel debuted a new
line of barbie dolls as part of their
thank you to heroes collections um the
brand spotlights women who were
real-life heroes during the pandemic las
vegas doctor audrey sue cruz was one of
the ladies selected earlier today
mercedes spoke with this hero check it
out
i'm so excited to talk to our next guest
dr audrey crews she is one of the front
line workers that is now a barbie doll
how are you and how does it feel to be a
barbie doll dr cruz oh my gosh mercedes
thank you so much i oh my god it feels
incredibly unreal it's it's a dream that
i thought that i never thought was
possible to be honest it's um it feels
surreal and honestly
i it's so humbling to me too because i
don't feel deserving but i'm just so
excited and i i think it's such an honor
for barbie to
to have this collection um you know for
frontline workers i think it's just such
an amazing and iconic thing to do but
i'm so excited thank you so much
mercedes it is part of the thank you
heroes program and it highlights the
work of frontline workers during this
pandemic so it's not just you it's it's
other women too that have been a big
part of this who are some of the other
barbies that they're featuring
yeah so they're featuring um another a
nurse um in the u.s she's in brooklyn
amy o'sullivan um
they're also honoring um
one of the um uk researchers who helped
develop the astrazeneca vaccine
a doctor from brazil who actually
sequenced the genome of covin-19
variant there
also a psychiatry resident who also
fought discrimination and racial bias
as well as a doctor in australia who um
made her own program to make gowns and
pbe more accessible to physicians and
healthcare workers so
it's an amazing group of women that just
have made such an impact and i'm honored
to be amongst them do you have the
barbie with you right now i do i do
right over here here oh
she's so beautiful thank you
i got every all the details right like
this is the inspiration for the um the
actual
barbie and so my the outfit that i'm
wearing and so they got all the little
details right including you know the
stethoscope the white coat they even
have a little mask right here so i
thought it was just incredible
i have to see the feet does she have
barbie feet on her tippy toes or no no
she's actually right on her feet it's
flat which is great because they're you
know she's wearing sneakers like the
rest of us
in the world that is perfect
it is so
amazing what you have done during this
pandemic dr cruz and being from las
vegas too you really are shining the
light on our wonderful community what
does las vegas mean to you
thank you oh my gosh to me las vegas is
home i moved here when i was five years
old this is where i grew up i went to
high school here my family lives here
so vegas is truly home and to be you
know recognized by the community is
totally it's just it means so much to me
and to be able to give back to the
community as a physician
now it truly is what i it's why i went
to medicine this is where i grew up and
i love i love las vegas